[Music]
the long-term planner ltp is now
open for your feedback and guess what
here it is we're trying to get a
summation
in under a minute mayor dan rates you're
trying to keep them low
yes we are and councils looking to defer
major or new projects where possible
but the district's still got issues
problems that will have to face over the
next 10 years yes there is
and there are four key areas that the
council will be focusing on
don't put your own pressure but you've
got 40 seconds what are they
they are ensuring our community
facilities can cater
for our growing population supporting
waimakari's covert 19
economic recovery preparing for the
impacts of climate change
and improving our district's
sustainability and looking at how the
government's
upcoming three waters reform would
impact us
that's four well done so
that's the ltp in a nutshell and we're
going to have more information incoming
videos yes
to find out more visit waimakarari.govt
dot
nz forward slash let's talk